bonjour bonjour à toutes et à tous
bonjour j mee bonjour federica et
bonjour aux langues rgo bonjour bonjour
à tous les autres tetris et à tous les
auditeurs de martinique 1ère vous êtes
conseillère municipale de fort de france
vous avez été élus en 2014 sur la liste
d'opposition dénommé faut que ça change
et faute france et puis vous êtes membre
dirigeant du palima le parti pour la
libération de la martinique relance grue
beau c'est d'abord la conseillère
municipale d'opposition que nous allons
interroger puisque vous êtes intervenu
lors du récent conseil municipal la
semaine dernière sur les conditions du
tournage d'un clip par là par l'artiste
kalach au quartier il faut y aller de
sainte thérèse
vous avez dénoncé les conditions de
tournage de ce clip et vous avez donc
admonesté vous avez interrogé en tout
cas au moins 9 le maire de fort de
france didier laguerre alors est ce que
c'est de la polémique politique
politicienne même j'ai envie de dire où
est ce que sur le fond vous estimez
qu'il ya lieu effectivement d'en faire
un débat de société peut-être oui je
pense que sur le fond il ya vraiment de
quoi revenir et je crois que nous devons
effectivement étudier un certain nombre
de questions sur la martinique et la
question de fond que je posais c'était
qu'il fallait que les politiques
peut-être aussi comme toute la société
martiniquaise se pose des questions sur
la façon de revoir un petit peu revoir
le développement économique et social de
la martinique parce que certain nombre
de personnes ont choisi un style de vie
qui n'est pas une réponse vraiment à nos
problèmes de chômage et donc au détour
de tournage on a vu que jeunes
certainement ou une personne de mauvais
style de vie d'hier on dise on nous a
répondu a menacé des policiers un
policier qui faisait une intervention et
dénonce un certain nombre de faits
justement sur ce ton âge et donc que
cette partie de la population que ces
personnes se sentent en
en mesure de faire de telles menaces
publiques parce que ça s'est fait par
voie de réseaux sociaux je crois que
cela doit interpeller tout le monde à
porter cela en conseil municipal
c'est une question de société que nous
devons régler parce que là le conseil
municipal était est un lieu où on règle
les poser l'atelier n'attaquez pas
finalement le maire de fort-de-france là
dessus noah thirion quand même la
tension nous tenions est attiré
l'attention parce que parfois le fait de
vouloir faire de la proximité nous
permet nous fait prêter le flanc à
certaines exagérations et nous avons
bien vu un que c'était au détour de ça
parce que le tournage a permis que dont
on a vu des jeunes et ils l'ont dit pour
des raison du tournage ils n'ont pas
porter le casque par exemple ce sont des
ce sont des signaux qu'il faut que noah
auquel il faut que nous fassions
attention on ne peut pas se permettre
tout et n'importe quoi
donc c'est que c'est un signal d'alerté
lancés plus qu'une joute politique une
attaque personnelle vis-à-vis du bien
entendu c'est vrai que lorsque nous
intervenons niveau du conseil municipal
souvent le prix à paris non mais parce
que dans ce propos il faut quand même
rappeler que comment dirais-je le maire
de fort de france a fait un communiqué
les noms mais il a fait un communiqué à
la suite des événements et surtout d'une
prise à partie de la part de d'un
certain nombre d'internautes
d'administrer et il a bien précisé qu'un
arrêté municipal avait été pris afin
d'assurer dans les règles le bon
déroulement le bon déroulement du
tournage voilà et que l'arrêté municipal
en question stipule est le respect par
le producteur donc de la société qui a
réalisé le clip du code de la route et
du code pénal et le problème c'est que
justement les conditions n'ont pas été
respectées puisque il y a eu un accroc
par exemple rien qu'au niveau du code de
la route parce qu'ils ont bien expliqué
que c'était pour les besoins du tournage
que l'on n'a pas mis les casques
alors au delà de ça il faut se poser la
question de quelle image nous voulons
vrai véhicule et de la martinique à
l'extérieur et puis quelle réponse en
fait nos politiques nos sociétés
martiniquaise posons à ce problème
economica martinique la question du
chômage et
nous savons que par exemple au niveau de
la ctm il ya un grand travail qui est
fait pour tout le monde connaît à toute
intrusion etc
il faut absolument que nous posions un
moment ce problème et cette mesure
retraite c'est tout inclusion atouts
inclusion c est ce que je retiens c'est
que lorsque nous parlons au niveau du
conseil municipal nous sommes pris à
partie j'ai été traitée de démagogues
je fais de la manipulation psychologique
simplement parce que j'attire
l'attention sur la nécessité que nous
fassions attention à nos actes à nos
façons d'agir mais surtout aussi à cette
nécessité de travailler ensemble à un
moment donné sur les problèmes les plus
importants notre société martiniquaise
hollande rugby parlons des finances de
la ville de fort de france alors votre
votre groupe vous est vent debout
là par contre clairement contre la
gestion municipale
vous dénoncez le déficit un fort déficit
bon avec l'appui du rapport de la
chambre régionale des comptes
évidemment vous ça va être un argument
de campagne pour les prochaines la
prochaine campagne municipale absolument
quelques mois absolument ça ne peut pas
être différent quand vous avez une dette
de 50 5 millions vous avez un budget de
2 103 millions un endettement de 230
millions n'ont absoluement il faut il
faut revoir sa copie et souvent quand
nous posons le problème du déficit de la
situation financière de fort de france
il nous aurait troqué que cette ce
déficit est ce déficit est à la limite
quelque chose qui date parce que on
avait en empêcher a aimé césaire depuis
sa mandature d'avoir de l'argent mais on
sait que depuis 2001 par exemple avec
l'élection de françois mitterrand il y a
eu des facilités porté à la ville et
nous savons que bon la villa fils de
fort de france a pu profiter des mânes
venue du conseil régional et du conseil
général notre temps et donc il faut
surtout se dire qu'il y à une mauvaise
gestion le clan que cette gestion
qu'est-ce que vous avez qu'est ce que
vous allez proposer
vous donc dans votre mouvement municipal
fox a changé faute france alors il est
évident que la première chose à faire ça
sera de faire un audit là ils ne peuvent
pas se permettre de faire un audit ils
sont entre eux donc quand on quand on
mène une ville quand on mène un budget
canton on travaille ensemble depuis plus
de 70 ans qui sont qu'ils sont là ils ne
vont pas pouvoir se permettre une
d'audit
alors que nous nous disons qu'il faut
entrer au fond des choses il faut
affronter des gens nous disent comment
vous allez vous en sortir comment nous
allons nous en sortir à fort de france
parce que parce que j'ai problème sent
tellement impuissant peut-être amené des
décisions je dirais sorte draconien et
donc mais nous restons des personnes
lucides la situation en martinique est
suffisamment catastrophique
il faudra qu'on prend une comprennent
des mesures adaptées
nous ferons preuve avait dégénéré un
parce que en même temps nous savons que
l'association pourrait même dépasser par
des recettes fiscales peut-être quand
même - si possible bien entendu
oui c'est toujours le moins possible
parce que autrement si on se dit ça on
se dit aussi que man à la limite ils
sont déjà là qu'il continue donc il faut
absolument se dire qu'il y as
possibilité de faire autrement
il préconise est pas une augmentation
des impôts n'ont surtout pas parce qu à
fort-de-france nous souffrons
suffisamment du montant des impôts plein
de personnes se plaignent du montant des
impôts alors que l'aco la commune
prétend ne pas avoir d'augmentation je
crois que la pression fiscale n'est pas
la solution que nous de leur taxe
d'habitation et la taxe d'habitation qui
va bien qui va disparaître il a pu
rentrer c'est ce sont des voix là mais
ça ne nous empêche pas ça ne nous fait
pas peur parce que nous avons nous
aurons le courage qu'il faut pour
affronter les difficultés des
difficultés puisque les perspectives se
serait que la ville de fort de france
puisse enfin se développer puisse enfin
connaître une vie meilleure et que les
habitants de fort de france soit
beaucoup plus satisfait de la ville et
que la martinique soit satisfaite de la
ville sa ville capitale vous décriez
également le fonctionnement de la caisse
des écoles de fort de france
vous posez la question ce qu'il ya une
bonne gestion
je suis je suis enseignante et j'entends
j'entends autour de moi les les
directeurs d'école tout le monde sait
que l'école primaire dépend de ce que
donne la mairie la municipalité et tout
autour de nous et nous savons que
il manque de laon qui manquent il manque
du papier les lignes téléphoniques le
téléphone les imprimantes
il y à toute une série de problèmes et
quand on sait que l'éducation c'est un
qui va nous permettre de nous en sortir
et donc l'éducation qui doit être une
priorité et qui à cause des problèmes
financiers que connaît la ville
cette priorité n'est pas vraiment
respectée donc il y aura effectivement
un travail absolument à faire là-dessus
même au niveau du sermac à nous avons
entendu dire qu'il y a des difficultés à
haut niveau de l'anc et tout ça des
matériels je crois que il faut que nous
arrivions à léguer certain nombre de
problèmes
il faut que ça se passe absolument
on est déjà à la conclusion relance
grumeaux conseillère municipale à
fort-de-france membres du pas nîmes
alors justement en faut que ça change
des fautes france se prépare évidemment
ça y est c'est décidé qui sera tête de
liste
francis carole rempile
il va aussi bien sûr puisque nous savons
que francis carroll dont il faut que ça
change et c'est quand même la deuxième
force politique à fort de france 1 il y
a eu une élection la dernière fois il ya
eu deux mi voix pour m partie comme un
bâton quand on n'a pas beaucoup de temps
est ce que vous n'avez pas un mot ou un
moment envie de renouveler je dirais un
peu la tête de liste c'est francesca
relancera à ça je sais plus troisième ou
quatrième tentative
vous savez que les élections ne sont pas
faciles nous avons une tête de liste est
déjà connue qui fait un travail
formidable qui est très apprécié de la
population martiniquaise pourquoi
changer c'est peut-être de l'iss et
pour une nouveauté qu'il faudra faire
connaître donc il ya eu des débats nous
avons bien discuté et ça change et s'est
arrêté celui qui mènera la liste pour
les prochaines élections et par contre
il faudra effectivement une mobilisation
générale parce que pour nous savons que
la liste la confusion était là nous
savons que la liste précédente
elle a une base il y à leur dirais entre
guillemets le fonds de commerce aimé
césaire et donc je crois que il faut
absolument qu'on se rende compte que ça
doit changer il faut que ça change et fo
de france
on nous fait tout pour ça changer votre
ans merci rowland rue bonne journée
merci à vous aussi